I'm not a philosopher,
so I'm going to dodge
the many complicated ethical
questions about cryonics,
about freezing someone's body
after they die
in the hope that future science will
not just unfreeze them,
but also cure them of
whatever ended their life.
The philosophical side of this is way
outside what I'm qualified to talk about!
And honestly, my opinion
would not be helpful.
I will say that I think death is
a bad thing, and that humanity
should be trying to defeat it,
the same way we've defeated smallpox.
But that is a controversial opinion.
The questions I do have for
the folks that run
this actual cryonics facility
are practical and legal.
As ever, this is not an advert.
The team here have no editorial control.
I just got invited to see a place
where the dead are being stored
in the hope of resurrection.
- Currently, there's still very
few patients stored here.
It's more than zero, but you can
count it on a very few hands.
The exact number we only release
once we have a few more, to
not have any potential privacy
problems, but it's very few so far.
- The company's official website
describes the bodies in there as
"patients", but what's being stored
are, legally and medically, corpses.
Not people.
The people have been declared
legally dead, and their assets
have passed to their descendants.
The cryo process cannot start
until the person is declared dead,
because otherwise it's murder.
So if someone who's signed up is
close to death, the company will
dispatch a very
non-standard ambulance.
- There needs to be the least possible
delay
between the heart stops and the
cool-down procedure being started.
And of course, only if the patient has
given informed consent before dying.
And then we start practically
three procedures at the same time.
One is we start cooling
down as quick as possible.
There's a saying in medicine
that says:
"you're only dead if you're
warm and dead".
The metabolic rate of the cell
goes down and the cell dies slower.
We also start very aggressive, what
is similar to CPR, chest compressions,
giving oxygen and so on, to give
some amount of metabolic support.
And before you cross 0°C,
you want to replace all the blood
and the rest of the water
against a medical grade antifreeze.
It's very important to say:
we don't freeze anything.
Though, of course, the headline
always says
"this organization is freezing people"
and so on!
In more technical terms, we vitrify
them,
which is a glass-like amorphous state,
which allows tissue to be stored
without any further damage, in a state
where potentially future technology
might be able to, well, resuscitate.
- The cryo process causes massive, probably
unrecoverable damage to the body.
There is no technology, now or
even vaguely on the horizon,
that could reverse that damage.
But whatever is left: patient, corpse,
assembly of frozen stuff,
gets stacked up in stainless steel containers here,
submerged in liquid nitrogen, until...
Well, until it's possible to recover
them, which could very well be never.
So, obvious question, how does a dead
person pay for a service that,
if all goes to plan,
will continue indefinitely?
- While someone is alive, there's a small
membership fee with us,
and then at the time of death,
it's around €200,000.
But this is a one time fee.
The largest part is given to
a non-profit organisation.
They invest that money,
with around 1-2% above inflation
in return expectations,
sufficient then to
maintain cryopreservation.
And you have that money that you
put aside,
inflation adjusted in the future,
for, well, whatever medical
procedure might be necessary,
to pay for reintegration, for retraining,
to get used to the future again.
One of the goals of our organization
is to, over time, not only make
the cryopreservation procedures
better, but also make it
significantly more affordable.
Somewhere in the mid-five-figure range,
maybe, should be possible over time.
- A reminder, that's the CEO of the company.
His view is going to be biased.
But one of the reasons I was comfortable
filming here is that
he was very candid about
the chances of this working.
- We would never state that there's
any "X percent" that this works.
Cryopreservation is not
a medical procedure.
It's a research procedure.
No one in the world can say if and
when cryopreservation might work.
Long term storage is always
done with foundations.
We have bylaws and statutes that make
the foundation,
from a day-to-day perspective,
very slow, very sluggish, and
there's a lot of inertia to change stuff.
All of that is there to
maximize for longevity.
I would like to live on as long as I can,
and as long as I want to.
I don't only want that for me, but I
think that should be everybody's right.
Ideally, I would never
like to be cryopreserved.
I would like to do whatever treatments
there will be when I'm 95, and
whatever medication I need to take
when I'm 60, to then make that happen.
Should I die at 60 of a heart attack
or something like that, then
I'd much rather be cryopreserved
than being cremated or buried.
It might turn out it never works,
but the alternative has as close to zero
a chance as you can ever have.
- This, right now, is an option for
a tiny minority of rich people,
and it probably won't work.
But I do think that humanity should
be trying to defeat death,
so I find it difficult to argue against
someone who'd take this option...
when I know what the alternative is.